hey guys this is Inka and in this video
I will only be eating green colored
foods for 24 hours I haven't done one of
these colored food challenges in a while
but I am very excited to get back into
it I've definitely done some pretty
bizarre colors in the past like blue and
clear so green relatively doesn't sound
as crazy even in our daily lives we see
a lot of naturally green colored food so
I do think that in this challenge I will
be eating a lot more as per usual I will
be making my meals from scratch using
only fruits that are naturally colored
green I have a feeling that today is
mostly going to be a lot of
experimentation and trying to combine as
many green things as possible we shall
see all right let's get cooking good
morning I have changed into the only
thing I have that is green let me show
you guys what ingredients I have to work
with for breakfast I have some super
greens which are really just a bunch of
leafy greens I have to buy one of these
because it's just such like a classic
green food I also have some kale and
spinach in my fridge I usually just buy
them anyways I found these really cool
tortillas this one is made with spinach
and herbs it's this like beautiful green
color honeydew kiwi avocado green grapes
granny smith apple and a pear I also got
this green salsa that I think would go
really well with the tortilla wrap that
I'm planning on making for those of you
who have been watching a lot of these
colored food challenges you know how
much I love fruit so I am very very
happy that I got to find it's so many
different kinds of fruit under the color
green as you guys can see there are a
lot of ingredients here this is going to
be a very nutritious breakfast so what
I'm thinking is I'm going to make a
breakfast smoothie
I'm gonna cut up some fruit and I'm
gonna have a wrap let's get started with
the smoothies since that's one of my
favorite things to have ready wash these
foods so I'm just going to chop up this
hair start off by putting in some pear
apples avocado also gonna add in a
squeeze of lime one or two groups is
getting really full spinach now to blend
it up
look at how green this is I love it I'm
gonna set this aside and I'm gonna work
on our tortilla wraps is what it looks
like it is fairly green they got Mikado
right in the middle a little bit of lime
I think a little bit of a super greens
and now we're gonna try and wrap it I
just need to cut my Kiwi up but then I
am ready to plate everything out and
here it is first meal of the day
my very green of breakfast look at how
good this looks
there's my green grapes the Kiwi the
honeydew and I cut up the wrap so you
can see the insides it is super super
green then over here of course I have my
green smoothie I am so pleased with how
this turned out and look how creamy this
smoothie looks because of the avocado
but this wrap you guys it is literally
filled to the brim with green stuff I
say green food challenge but honestly
this is this is more like 24 hours of
eating eating really healthy I am very
ready to tuck in I'm gonna start by
taking a sip of this smoothie I love
this consistency it's like a milkshake
there is that very very subtle sweetness
of the pear and there's a little bit of
tartness from the Granny Smith apple but
mostly I just taste the avocado this for
sure is something that I would most
likely be drinking every day if I could
next up are my food honeydew
there's my green Kiwi look at how green
that is I love Kiwis
wow those Kiwi is super-sweet I
should've put in this new thing some
classic green grapes oh I love it I love
being able to eat so much fruit on this
challenge I've been holding this off
because I was so excited about it my rap
I take a big bite it's a very clean
taste this is such a great way to have a
light breakfast but it can still keep
you full and to lunch
green foods day is going fairly well so
far
breakfast was such a delight to have I
was able to have a lot of things that I
normally really love so I am actually
really looking forward to the rest of
the day I'm going to continue sipping at
my smoothie as I work at my desk
and I will check back in when it's
lunchtime it is lunchtime and I am
pretty excited I have been waiting the
past couple hours since breakfast
because there's so much to work with I
think lunch is gonna be pretty amazing
even just by looking at what I have here
you guys can see that there's a lot of
green going on I have a little bit of
okra here
zucchini lime green bell pepper cilantro
this is green tea noodles fYI this is
the packaging for it you can see that
it's made from green tea which is pretty
awesome
as somebody who really likes green tea
the flavor actually doesn't stand out
too much but it comes out this beautiful
green there's bok choy which has always
been a staple for me growing up and then
over here I just have some scallion a
jalapeno a few of these items will be
used more for garnishing purposes and
then over here I actually have some
leftovers that I ordered yesterday this
is a Thai green curry from one of my
favorite restaurants here in New York
the restaurant is called fish cheeks
this is one of my favorite curries from
them I already kind of poked at it
yesterday but there's some cauliflower
in here still I think some snap peas and
a bit of okra which all qualifies so I
kept them in here and then this is
Morning Glory which is another one of
the vegetables that I grew up eating a
lot their stem is hollow so they have
like a crunch here
texture which is really nice so I was
thinking I would add this on top of the
noodles last but not least I have this
really special seafood sauce and the
reason it's such a vibrant green usually
is because for this one I know they used
Thai bird's eye chili and then there's
also cilantro in here some lime garlic
and of course some fish sauce this is
magical there's so much flavor packed
into it so I wanted to just also add a
little bit to this dish I really just
like how this looks so much green since
I already have my green curry here which
is gonna act as my noodle broth I am
going to get started with cutting of
vegetables and also cooking the noodles
first step should be to wash the
vegetables all washed and ready just to
keep to the theme I'm actually going to
only use the green bits here instead of
the white parts all my veggies are now
prepped add blue roses and you guys see
that it is like a darker green than like
a vibrant green this is definitely a
greener color now that the flower has
been washed away so I'm gonna rinse this
really quickly now I can start working
on the soup broth for the rest of today
I'm just gonna be using avocado oil
since it just seems appropriate because
avocado green gently fry up some of
these vegetables add in the green
Oh toss in my book row also to the bok
choy and now I'm just going to let it
simmer and let the vegetables soften a
little then it's pretty much done one
should be ready
all right it is done and it is super
super packed with vegetables look at
this oh my goodness there's at least ten
different types of vegetables in here I
love how this turned out because there's
like lighter shades darker shades and
there's like a good combination of like
flavors it's just very healthy at the
same time it looks really delicious
let me just drizzle on the sauce for
that final finish I can smell it from
here there's a lot of spice I mean
there's a lot of green chili in this
excited I'm gonna pair this meal with
this green juice I bought yesterday it
has a bunch of stuff in there here
greens it says very very green meal
today still a green noodle pool I'm like
already salivating you're still looking
at it here we go oh yeah tastes like
normal noodles but with the added
benefits of green tea I guess I also
love cilantro I think it adds so much to
every type of sauce broth exacta goes
great with noodles here's that morning
glory when you bite into it it just has
like like big crunch also the green
peppers have now become a lighter green
they're super soft and tender now oh the
bok choy zucchini so they like
completely soaked up that green curry
flavor man this is really good not sure
if I should be eating the entire slice
here I'm just gonna do it for you guys
you went across time for some use they
weren't kidding when they said purely
just vegetables because there's no added
sweetness in this at all only the
natural sweetness of whatever vegetables
in here and there's not a lot of that
very very healthy you know how sometimes
things just taste super healthy
this is one of those instead of just
going straight to salads there's so many
other ways we can cook vegetables I feel
like I could eat a whole bowl of
vegetables cooked in this broth I am
very very happy with this dish I think I
got to eat a lot of vegetables very
satisfied I am now gonna go back to work
see if there's anything else I need to
get for dinner I will see you guys then
hello hello it is a little early for
dinner right now but I went shopping
earlier and I found this I had to buy
this because I feel like the ones we
usually see are made with spinach and
this one actually comes in the form of
lasagna sheets I am very excited to cook
with this so let's check out the
ingredients first off we have our green
light - lasagna and then I have some
asparagus some spinach I have some
store-bought pesto here tomatillos these
are actually most commonly used in salsa
verde which is again a beautiful green
it has more of a tangy flavor Brussels
sprouts are zucchini again some fresh
basil and some fresh oregano and then I
also have this really special sauce the
type of ramp sauce made by my friend
Eric ramps are also known as wild leeks
and it's probably the most similar to
green onions but I feel like they have
an even more pungent flavor which I
really like so I'm planning on utilizing
this too once more you can see that we
have a lot of ingredients to work with
there's a lot of green on here so I'm
gonna figure out how to use each of them
one by one starting with roasting some
vegetables
[Music]
now I'm going to pop it in the oven
alright so my vegetables have been
roasted and over here are you already
cut up my tomatillos basically what I'm
gonna try and do is just combine these
vegetables together to make a sauce of
sorts that can go with the pesto it is
an interesting blend of sauces normally
I would never cook my pesto but for this
one I am trying to wing it I'm calling a
lasagna because it's based on the
concept of lasagna but whether it is
actually lasagna is debatable this is
what I have it is you know it definitely
looks a little bit interesting a lot
more dewy than I wanted it to be I am
just going to go with this and assemble
my lasagna now maybe I shouldn't have
aimed for lasagna after all but I really
want to see if I can make it happen so I
am just going to keep going first things
first I'm gonna put a layer of this
sauce with some spinach on here check
out my lasagna sheets is definitely a
greenish yellow color it's actually kind
of pretty from the layer down on add on
the sauce again add my zucchini in here
basil just trying to see what would work
together going to put on some of the
pesto cheese is super vibrant green and
forget my sauce just reach in it this is
definitely one of my wildest experiments
last thing is just to sprinkle on some
fat asparagus this is my green lasagna
super super green I'm gonna put this in
the oven it shouldn't have to cook too
long and hopefully it's gonna turn out
good also while I'm waiting I'm just
snacking on a little bit of green peas
crisps they actually look like green
peas which i think is super cute and
they're super crunchy it's a perfect
light snack to have before dinner
this actually does taste like Greenpeace
or I guess that's one way of getting
your vegetables in so I just pulled it
out of the oven and it doesn't look so
green anymore you can still see the
asparagus and the zucchini which I threw
in I'm just going to add some basil back
in and yep that sit I guess this is my
garden lasagna of sorts I'm gonna try
and cut a slice and then plate it up for
our meal this is what there's a lot of
layers going on here what it basically
did was stack two on top of each other
it does kind of look like a lasagna
though right and there's no cheese but
you do get like the creaminess of that
tomatillo sauce we made still smells
like pesto then I have my green tea here
it's a very faint green I definitely
took a lot of Liberty with this one I am
super curious to know how it tastes okay
I can cut it cross-section looks okay
I see the layers there the green lentil
pasta is surprisingly good you do get
some of that green lentil flavor but the
texture of it is so much like regular
lasagna sheets which is very surprising
because I'm so used to it being more
brittle in terms of the sauce I think
I'm just very confused because there's
so many flavors going on but I do feel
like one of the dominating flavors is
the tomatillo sauce we made green tea is
always nice overall I think it's not bad
I don't think I'd be making it again I
do think that I overwhelmed this a
little bit by trying to combine too many
green sauces anyways I'm gonna finish
this up and wrap up what's left over and
then since there's still some time in
the day I am actually going to make a
dessert later a dessert that I'm really
looking forward to so I hope you are too
it is finally the end of day and that
means that it is time for dessert and
knowing that I'm doing green foods
challenge that means
I'm gonna be using this opportunity to
eat as much
matcha as I possibly can I am a bit of a
matcha fanatic I love anything green tea
/ matcha flavored so I thought for
dessert it would be really fun if I made
a super extra over-the-top matcha
parfait
I basically sourced as many much a
product as I can as well as making some
of my own using the matcha powder I have
at home so then I can build a very very
green very much a glorious perfect let
me show you how much matcha products I
have right now look at all this stuff I
have over here watch it burn Ola matcha
wafer cookies matcha cake matcha
chocolate I made some matcha syrup
matcha whipped cream and then I also
made some matcha jelly I also have my
green tea ice cream then I actually have
this green rice you heard that right
this is actually green rice look at this
color it's not so cool so the reason it
has this green color is because the rice
has been infused with bamboo extract I
had no idea this existed until I was
sourcing for green things and I found
this so but that being said it's going
to be a pretty epic parfait first thing
I'm gonna do is I actually toast these
green rice bits a little bit so then I
can make them essentially into little
rice puffs
they have turned a little brown now
they've lost a little bit of their green
color but now they're just like toasty
little rice krispies which i think will
be a really nice little surprise in the
park day I am now ready to assemble my
Mary much up our peg gonna start off
with some of my whipped cream
Finola add a little bit of ice cream
jelly put some more cream sprinkle my
rice puffs in here I'm gonna add these
little snacks cut up some more cream
that's good
just gonna add a big scoop of ice cream
I'm also cutting up my cake I totally
trimmed off the brown bits so then
everything that's left is just green off
to the sides
matcha chocolate right here finishing it
off with a drizzle as matcha here it is
this is Mike aureus matcha parfait it
actually looks pretty good right you can
see all the layers in there there's like
at least nine to ten things in here this
might be the best dessert I've made yet
I am so excited to eat this this looks
so good
I would totally buy this I don't have a
parfait spoon so I'm just using my
wooden spoon here I'm not have a bite of
my ice cream first show good show mantra
oh I have a scoop of a lot of things in
here I got the jelly thought the wafers
got my crispy rice which actually goes
with the matcha so well because of that
toasty flavor if you love matcha I think
you would love this I think it's safe to
say that I had a lot of fun this
challenge I really truly enjoyed every
single meal I think dinner was the only
one that was a little like interesting
but I'm really glad I'm ending today on
a very green a very much a parfait and
I'm looking forward to my next color
food challenge I will see you guys then
I
[Music]